good afternoon everyone can you hear me
all right at the back
great so uh my name's edwin this is uh
miles
sabin um that little
faffing about here was because neither
of us has ever used the computer before
i'm afraid and we were
we've we've actually worked out how to
get the thing talking so hopefully
nothing else will go wrong
uh for the oh
um you know actually i you know i'm just
teasing i'm sorry
um so if you've used the computer before
you'll find this thing happens to you
all the time uh you're doing something
in front of an audience and you try to
make things go and then something
goes badly wrong sometimes it's a bit
less serious so
i'm typing merrily away or i'm browsing
a website and and
congratulations mozilla firefox is not
responding
um so this sort of thing happens uh
this sort of thing might happen if
you're if you're out shopping
uh you put your credit card into the
card reader
and you get a segmentation fault and i
don't know about you
but if the card reader is is seg
faulting i don't particularly
trust it with my credit card data so
what do you do when these things happen
i mean this is
this is all computers going wrong we're
all kind of used to this now i mean the
way
the fact that you're laughing suggests
that you recognize these situations what
we typically do
is we turn it off and on again don't we
and then we just carry on and we're fine
now it's not always it's not always
going to work turning it off and on
again so are there any rocket scientists
in the room
okay that's disappointing um so
does anyone recognize this
it's a spaceship well done yeah
is it one of the mars satellites that
never made it into orbit
yeah so this is the mars climate orbit
that's actually an artist's impression
of the mars climate auditor because
i don't know if nasa advertised but they
were having trouble finding
photographers who wanted to go out to
the
orbit of mars the other reason it's an
artist's impression
is uh what it was supposed to do was go
to mars uh be a relay for the miles polo
lander
monitor the the climate of mars and send
details back to earth
what it actually did was crash straight
into mars
and um the the reason it crashed was
actually quite interesting for me
is a type theorist the reason it crashed
into mars was um ground-based software
that was working in imperial units and
and the orbiter itself was working in
metric units
so this is uh in my world this is a type
error i mean in a
in any reasonable world this is a type
error we're using the wrong types for
these things but in a
in a mainstream ordinary programming
language this isn't a type error because
you know they're both integers or
floating point numbers or whatever
so what i'm going to talk about and what
we're going to talk about together
is how we can use types to help
write correct software i'm going to talk
about it from one perspective
from the the idris programming language
perspective the uh full dependent types
perspective
and then miles is going to tell us a bit
about um how this can work
in a mainstream programming language we
can call scala mainstream these days
can't we
i think that's yeah yeah good so time
systems offer lots of things so we heard
a lot about this this morning in
martin odersky's talk um so we we we
present types as a way of checking
programs for correctness but there's a
lot more to it than that and it's not
just like
you know the type system is there to
tell you off when you did it wrong the
type system is also there
to help guide you towards a program that
actually works so
personally i uh i do a lot of my
programming in haskell so if i add a
field to a data type in haskell
what do i do i have the field i don't
then go through my entire program
searching for all the places where this
where this data type exists i just hit
compile and let the machine tell me
where i need to fix things up and i find
this greatly helps my development time
also types are there to help us build
some expressive libraries
to help us with generic programming and
we'll see a little bit of examples of
this
as we go on so we're going to talk about
dependent types
type dependent types are kind of if if
you imagine the uh
the graphs that we had in this morning's
keynote on type systems is kind of
far off the top right uh sort of i think
roughly in this room relative to where
the uh
where the uh where the slide was um
and i'm gonna show two different pro
we're going to show two different
approaches
to programming with dependencies
basically types that are allowed to be
predicated on values and this could mean
a whole lot of different things
uh precisely what we mean by that really
depends on the setting that we're
working in
so i'm going to talk about idris which
is um a new programming language that
i've been working on for
well actually a few years now where the
idea is
we've got dependent types how can we
build a language from the ground up that
is
general purpose practical usable for
real stuff
and then in contrast to that uh miles
will show you know i'm going to
set some challenges and i'm going to
show you some idris programs and miles
is going to say
i can do that in a in a mainstream
language what are you
theoretical uh geeks on about
no okay he's super light we're both
british so we're quite you know polite
and friendly
um so i haven't got the boxing gloves on
that some people seem to expect
um okay so just to set the scene uh i'll
give you
some uh examples of idris programs now
if you're familiar with haskell uh
it's who's familiar with haskell around
the room ah
brilliant that's that's actually most of
you uh so
um if you're um if you're familiar with
haskell all these examples that i show
you
in the address notation will be quite
familiar you'll notice a few
tiny differences and i'll i'll draw your
attention to them as we go on
the firstly um natural numbers uh this
is obviously uh
so the natural numbers can be either
zero or the successor of a natural
number so
you know just counting a pile of
potatoes i suppose
um and uh obviously this is a completely
mad way to represent numbers on a
computer because uh
maxine takes about four gigabytes if you
if you store it this way
but we do have we do have some
optimization tricks to make that work a
bit better but the reason we do
uh describe uh numbers in this way is
that they have
you can very clearly see what the
structure is you can see how
the numbers are built up and you can
start relating them to other structures
that you might want to work with
so here's one other structure you might
want to work with that has a
similar sort of well structure to
natural numbers
so lists now you'll notice here i've
declared this data type in a rather
different style i've said that list
is a type constructor so this colon here
is a is a
typing judgment it's unlike haskell
where you have a double colon for typing
judgments we have a single colon now
this
this is a kind of a sort of bike
shedding
sort of point but the reason we have a
single colon rather than a double
is that i feel i'm going to be writing
an awful lot more types so i just want
to hit the button once
and besides mathematicians have been
using a colon for the typing judgment
forever so
why shouldn't we um so list is you can
reread this as a function type it's it's
a
function from types to type so we have
an element type and it just gives us a
type
so nil that's the empty list nil is a a
list of some element type a
and then cons so i've got a double colon
for the the cons constructor
given some a and a list of some a's
that'll give us back another list of a
so that's a fairly
standard way of presenting linked lists
so what about dependent types well we
can relate
we can give this very precise
relationship between data types by
giving it a dependent type so
a vect a vector here we unhopefully we
call them vectors it's
it's standard in the dependently typed
literature basically lists with size
so vector is uh indexed over a nat which
will represent its length
uh and an element type so now we
explicitly say that nil
has zero things in it and we explicitly
say
that given some element and given some
vector of k things
i'll give you back a vector of successor
of k things so
nil and cons we've used the same names
because we're going to use a lot of
differently decorated
uh list data types so i want to come up
with you know 100 different names for
these constructors
and they'll just get disambiguated by
the type checker now
if we have um types indexed over other
types so those those
types have a strong relationship to some
other type then it follows that any
program we write over those types
is also going to express that
relationship so append here
we have an input vector of length m an
input vector of length
m and an output vector of length m plus
n so if i
somehow manage to write this append
function in a way that doesn't preserve
that that that length property
i'm going to get a type error so there
we go uh
empty list plus y's is wise x cons x is
plus y
gives us x cos x plus y so you can read
the program just like
any ordinary program that you might
write in a functional language such as
haskell
maybe a bit more interestingly we can we
can have
a function such as this vector addition
so it's pairwise addition
a vector so corresponding elements in
vectors
are going to be added um so we've got a
vector of n things going in
another vector of n things going in and
it has to be a vector of n things that
comes out
otherwise this won't type check this
this constraint here num a
well if you're a haskell programmer
you'll recognize this is a type class
constraint so we have
type classes it just means that the a's
have to be something we can do numeric
operations on
now one thing i draw your attention to
is that i only have i have the two
inputs here that are nil two inputs here
that are cons
and there's no point in me giving the
cases for you know nil
added with cons cons added with nil
because well they're not going to type
check
so if you've ever um if you haven't
written something in haskell using
something like zipwhiz
you might find that you know you've got
two lists of different lengths and you
don't get
the type error until runtime if your
lists don't happen to be the same length
so zip width we can write two zip width
is pretty much the same thing it's just
that we've lifted out the function so we
have higher order functions as well
and yeah follows the same structure
now here's the key thing that uh when
we're teaching
when we're teaching people functional
programming we often say things like our
functions are first class now
well in idris types are first class so
you can compute with types
just like you can compute with anything
else so we don't actually have
a different type language so one thing
that came up in this morning's talk was
that
as you get richer type systems your your
type language gets more complicated
well it doesn't have to because all we
do is we use exactly the same language
no problem so here what we're doing is
we're calculating a type from
the the function i'm trying to write
here is a sort of variatic adder so it's
an adder
that takes a number of numbers and i'm
going to say in the first argument how
many numbers i'm going to how many more
numbers i'm going to take
so if if it's a 0 then i'm not going to
take any more arguments i'm just going
to give you a nat
and if it's a successor i'm going to ask
for another number
and return the rest of the type so the
function the adder function looks a bit
like this
uh adding 0 to an accumulator just gets
the accumulator so this
we we've we're sort of calculating the
type from this first input so this n
here is bound here and returns a new
type here
so actually it's probably best if i just
show you these things running
because then you might actually believe
this language exists you don't really
need to see my twitter
feed do let's turn that off
or read my emails as they crop up um
so um here's our adder so
um you can you can download and run this
if the wireless is working by the way
just like cabal install idris
and then you know tell me about all the
errors and if you're just playing with
that then i don't really mind if you
don't listen to miles
sorry did i say that out loud um so
here's our adder program um
i guess i could just run that so if i
type out of four it gives me the type of
out of four
so it's expected it's actually expecting
five more things because i'm giving the
accumulator two
uh so that we oh no it's expecting five
more things
there we go if i give it too many more
things it says well you can either read
this as it went wrong
or you can sort of mentally say that
turn those into nats which
it doesn't have a function type so we've
got some basic ideas here about how to
write programs with expressive types we
can we can calculate
um function types so we can be more
generic and we can
um just swap over now and i'll pass over
a minute
um and and we can give precise um
uh types that make sure our program is
correct so
um can you do that uh
do you want to take some questions yeah
we've had a bit of an issue with his
computer because i have a mac
so it worked um
so if there's any questions while we're
swapping then
oh yes sorry um
uh well your imagination really because
you can write any
well okay two answers to that i suppose
the first one is just your imagination
the second is well you have to be a
little bit careful not to allow too much
in the types because if you put a
program in a type that doesn't terminate
well that means your type checker isn't
going to terminate and that's
you know not ideal you can just hit ctrl
c of course um
so we do have a we do have a restriction
that the only things which the machine
is certain terminates can go in types
but that's about it really that's
suddenly lots of hands are cropped up so
you were first i think
so what is the performance of this thing
because as far as i understand some of
the independently type things
ah well that um that opens a can of
worms
and i would be happy to talk about that
for the next two hours
but i shouldn't um really we have more
precise types
so the compiler knows more about what
the program's supposed to do
so that should be good news and it
almost is
it's just it's a research problem uh so
i did my
phd on this so it was it was a topic i
worked on for a long time so i have done
quite a bit of work on
type eurasia and and removing things
that aren't run
on there at runtime and in practice we
find the performance is okay
uh but yeah and it's an interesting
topic so you've had your hand up for
ages
yeah so you can just calculate it um
based on some other input
so um i mean typically you'd have a
function calculating the length and then
you'd put that in your type
so yeah you can abstract over that sort
of thing in fact i've got things just
there's a tutorial for address and it's
got things just like that so um
how are we doing we're just about there
now oh brilliant okay
um so i just wanted to just wanted to um
excuse linux actually it's not really
linux's fault here the problem is that
i'm actually running x monad as my
window manager which of course as
everybody knows is written in haskell
[Laughter]
okay so what i'm going to do first is
i'm going to sort of do a little
a little demonstration of of the uh the
vector types
um that uh edwin was talking about um
previously
so i've translated um edwin's extremely
succinct
code so succeed that i think basically
if you blinked you you would also miss
it
into scala which is which is somewhat
more verbose but not
not appallingly so let's put it that way
it's i i i reckon that the um
the the the code size uh increase is uh
it's a constant factor let's put it that
way um
but actually actually actually um if you
think about it quite carefully that's
that's actually a win
i mean in terms of what what's being
expressed
uh by the types here we have types which
are indexed by
uh by by natural numbers um you know
that's but
potentially the the the the expansion is
is
is is arbitrary um uh linear potentially
linear in the size
size of the the list you might be
working with so the fact that we can
keep the code expansion to
to a constant size and actually
something which is not totally
illegible which does have some relation
back to to to to the sort of
the succinct um first class dependently
type stuff
that edwin showed us i think i think is
actually is actually um
quite remarkable in a language which is
is as edwin said a mainstream language
like scala
okay so let's take a look at an example
of a
a size checked list and let's just try
those uh those examples that
that those functions that it'd been
defined so i'm just going to
type in a couple i've used a slightly
different
constructor cons constructor here
because
scala already has what scala already has
uh
a double colon cons constructor so we're
having a little hash in there for
uh for uh
for uh to indicate numerics okay so we
can immediately see there's an
interesting type appeared on the
um on the on the ripple here um
i've actually found it would be quite
nice of some way of abbreviating type
signatures on the rebel because they do
tend to
blow up quite quite severely okay so you
can you can see
that what we have here is we have a um
we have a
cons list type uh so the colon colon
hash colon is
that's that's the type constructor uh we
can see that it's the the element type
is is an integer so it's index
that's that's the elements of the list
and you can see that we have
a um a type which looks remarkably
similar to the
uh to the the numeric the natural number
types that that have been
uh mentioned on his very first slide so
we have uh an initial zero
uh because we are not uh in living in a
world where we
can share uh elements between the value
level and the type level
we have to invent a new constant a
constant type underscore zero
representing
uh the natural number zero at the the
type level but then having got that
then we just uh iterate the successor uh
uh
type level successor function uh across
that to get
to uh the the correct number of elements
for the list
which is um it may actually look like
this is a list of length
two uh because you've got zero
successive successor uh it actually
turns out that
um that um the way you could read
this type as encoded in in in scala the
the actual cons element is as
an integer uh prepended to a list of two
elements so this is an actual fact
corresponding to a vector of type
uh uh with with three elements okay so
let's let's
um now add uh let's have
a uh let's give that a name
okay
let's um uh boring and unimaginative for
this
okay uh and now if we do uh l
one um
concatenated with l two you can see we
have
a now even more exciting type um
so we have um okay we have we we have
we have we have the list exactly that we
expect and you can see that it's length
it has been encoded in in
in the type so we have an additional
couple of uh applications of the
successor type constructed to
our zero to get us up to a list of
length five
just do a quick v add example
so if we were to do l1 v
at l2 we hope that this will fail
it should do and fail not in the sense
of a runtime exception it should
fail with uh it should fail with a
compile-time error and goodness me it
does
we have a tight mismatch um so let's do
this again
let's take
l um is um
what should we have let's have six
stuck on the front of l2
and now if we do that
success so um that's demonstrating
that's demonstrating the way that
um uh demonstrating that that the types
are actually actually doing some useful
work for us here they're verifying that
the property that we're hoping
uh we're expecting to hold does actually
hold um it works reasonably smoothly
there's a couple of other things which
kind of drop out of this quite nicely as
well
um if we take a look at l2 that's a two
element list
one of the i mean as well as the sort of
very typical problem of trying to zip
uh differently length lists together a
very common problem is is
attempting to take the head or a ten of
an empty list so something which
drops out of this kind of representation
immediately is
is is the fact that attempting to do
that becomes a
type error now this one will succeed
as indeed this one
but if we do it again because remember
this is a two element list
it's a type error it's not a runtime
error it's a type error
okay so what i'm going to very very
quickly do is i'm not going to go into
very many details of the code because
unfortunately there are lots of fiddly
little details which relate to the way
in which the encoding
of of uh edwin's edwin codes maps into
the scarlet which
i i this this is not the right time i
think or place to
to to discuss the the the the quirks of
the encoding
i just want to show you uh a couple of
uh relevant lines of the code which
which will map
very directly onto the idris that that
edwin showed
just bear with me for a second why try
and find the right screen
i was going to say that was i did go so
well right that's fine
okay so um so basically the way that
this ends up translating
into um into scala is that we
we we actually end up representing um
the dependently type functions functions
which are as well as computing values or
also computing
computing types we represent those as uh
abstract types in scala this is this is
i think the most straightforward way of
doing it
um and then um the abstract type
uh rather than doing the sort of the
pattern match case analysis type
uh implementation that edwin uh
demonstrated with idris
we end up uh resolving the independent
cases using using implicit resolution
but aside from the um aside from the
the the the the additional verbosity uh
in in the scarlet it is essentially
doing exactly the same thing
so this is the the the um encoded
signature of a dependently type function
from uh x's and y's that's our two
um uh size uh two vectors of of of
of values um
and we are going to be computing from
them um a value of some
result type the result type itself is
going to be a vector
of the element type with
the computed sum
type the sum of the the lengths of the
two constituent lists
and you can see here that this has
basically been left abstract and the way
to read this i guess is if
you could just imagine sort of folding
the individual lines up reading it as a
single line
as kind of kind of a kind of a
dependently typed function signature
with um with this this um this
component the the type being part of the
if you like the output of the function
in the same way that the value
is is also a part of the output of the
function and again i think whatever
edwin's saying about sort of merging the
two levels and only having only having
to have one
is some somewhere else where where where
he he wins in terms of simplicity
okay so for for this concat case we have
two two cases we have we have um
the the the empty concatenating an empty
list
with a non-empty list and you can see in
this instance
we are so we have two our two arguments
the first is
is an empty list of a's and the second
is a list
with n a's uh we can see that we've
we've set the the result type is going
to be n
because uh zero plus n is n and
the uh the result value is is the second
argument
so that's that's the if you like the the
base case for our our induction
and then for the the the v cons case
um again this code actually if we
compare this this bit
here to what edwin had on his slide
it's actually pretty much identical um
now okay laughter aside this is the fact
that we can do this in scarlet at all
is really quite remarkable i think i
think people should should um
not not not uh not um not
uh scoff too much i mean there really
are very very few i mean you can encode
this kind of stuff in haskell scott
haskell has recently grown
the ability to sort of promote types of
uh uh to
promote uh data types from the the value
level to the type level which makes kind
of this particular thing
a lot easier but until then actually the
the haskell is
encoding isn't much less heavyweight
than this and and the haskell encoding
uh even with data even with data type
promotion i mean
it covers a small number of ad hoc cases
and as soon as you stray outside of
those you end up back with stuff which
is not far off from this
but anyway i digress so i just very
briefly before i go back to open
the the the the um the recursion case
is um it's again fair it's fairly
straightforward
this time again due to some of the
quirks of the encoding
we actually need to um uh produce
a uh if you like
a witness for the uh concatenation
applied to um uh the the tail of the
first list
um and there are certain ways that edwin
is able to kind of just basically get by
with
structural recursion that can't be done
here and i need an explicit
uh an explicit implicitly uh constructed
proof term for for the tail of the list
but that's basically what's going on so
we're just
doing exactly the same thing that he's
doing
where we're taking the head of the first
list and sticking that on
the uh the recursive concatenation of
the the tail of the first list with
with with the second and that will
eventually wind us back down to the to
the nil case
and the the main thing is that we can
see is that
uh we're both computing the value and we
are also computing
um the um uh the the the new size of the
list so we are
because we just peeled off one element
from the first list we're saying that
the size of the resulting list is the
successor of the style
size of the concatenation of the tail um
and that this incidentally uh most of
most of what i'm showing you here is
stuff that you would um it has uh conor
mcbride
doing this kind of thing in haskell has
described as faking it
faking dependent types in haskell most
of what i'm showing you here actually is
uh is faking it sort of the tight classy
sort of approach to doing it
but things like um this um the the
using the the type member of the
implicitly summoned value that's a
genuine scalar dependent type that's a
path dependent type here and that's
kind of a key element of the encoding
and
sort of the joke i like to make about
this is that in in haskell um
people use type level functions to to
encode
uh dependent types whereas in skylab we
use dependent types to encode type level
functions
okay i think back to edward okay um
so i think it's great that this even
works at all in scotland it's what he's
done is quite impressive
but
none of this is getting our spacecraft
to mars
or uh i mean it's the the correctness is
of you know functions is one thing it's
the correctness of
um the non-functional stuff that uh that
you know really gets interesting so um
i think i'm just going to go straight to
the demo rather than
so something that
something else we can do is is reason
about uh non-functional properties
extra functional properties so resource
usage protocols so for example
if you want to read from a file read the
contents of a file print it out to the
screen
certain number of things have to happen
in the right order so you have to open
the file you have to open it for reading
you don't have to read it you have to
print to it you have to be in a context
where you can print because you know
maybe you're running on a
on an embedded system or something or
and then ideally you'll close the file
before you finish and
this sort of thing well okay files we
typically get right
um i say we typically get them right
idris had turned out to have a resource
leak bug where a file was being left
open for a while
so you know these things do happen if
you're being a little bit sloppy
i like dependent types because i'm just
sloppy and they tell me when i'm doing
things wrong
so i have an example here of a
no this is just to prove that it really
is checking
um so i have an example here of a
program that
that that satisfies a uh resource usage
protocol so this this is a program which
uh
opens a file reads from it uh prints the
contents prints the number of lines and
then closes
it now you might say where are the
dependent types there i don't see any
dependent types there
and i will say isn't it brilliant that
you can't see any dependent types there
it's full of dependent types the
dependent types are actually inside
managing the effects you have managing
the state transitions and making sure
you get them right
so if i scroll up to the top here see
this mysterious
f line it says okay a file program is
something that runs in a side affecting
environment
it's allowed to do file i o and the file
i o is in this
state so that state can either be empty
open for reading open for writing
we are allowed to do i o so we can do
console i o
and we can count there's a labeled state
we have a we're carrying a state which
is an integer
and we're counting the number of lines
so in this program
down here i'm allowed access to all of
those side effects that i've declared
now this f language
is it's just a huge abstraction over all
of the possible
transitions we can be doing all the
possible side effects that we're making
now if i type check this then well
uh takes a second or two but then it
type checks and it's fine and it works
and i can
i can even compile and run it i've
prepared a file so it actually does
print the contents of the file uh in a
straight format but never mind
um now what happens if i forget to close
the file
now normally now you just compile and
run and you never notice
what happens here is it says
well error messages are hard so i print
them in two ways this first one in this
case you might as well read that as it
went wrong
the second one zooms in on the actual
problem it says can't unify
empty with a file that's open for
reading so your clue there is
hmm i have something open for reading
and it shouldn't be
so the dependent types here are just
giving us that
that safety in resource usage protocol
safety and state management and this
sort of state management comes up
in um in apis all the time so
can you do that
so um
okay any questions yes
yeah it's not specifically about
resource management but you said earlier
that even though you're using
the um like the church encoding of
numbers that actually you're gonna do
something more efficient behind the
scenes can you speak at all so like how
your runtime does that like what sort of
limitations are i mean if i
want to use like you know more than a
64-bit how does it sort of
transition it's quite simple really it's
uh underneath it's gmp
so gmp integers and it's a it's a it's a
uniform translation of patterns and
values so every time it sees
z it puts o every time it sees
successor of something it translates
that to n plus one and every time it
sees
plus it translates that to the plus
function
so also underneath um uh
it sort of promotes from an integer to
gmp like machine engine to gmp if it
gets too big
so i haven't really measured that
performance in general
i find that it doesn't really matter
that we're using unary numbers because
they tend to stay at the type level they
tend not to end up in the resulting
program
so um yeah right so
um so uh
edwin sent me the challenge of
translating his uh his uh effects dsl
by the way um
and i i because i i've been working i've
been working on my
my library shapeless uh for quite some
time and
looking really reading through his paper
and looking at some of the things that
involved in it i i had a hunch that
that it would be possible to do it i
didn't think it was going to be
particularly pretty or particularly easy
but i thought i thought something
something would be doable
so i spent um i guess somewhere between
a week and a week and a half
kind of banging banging banging my head
on on on on on the scala type checker
trying to see if
i could actually get it to do it i got
close but i think ultimately
ultimately uh ultimately i failed um
it's not a terrible failure i in the
sense that um the type
the type system is actually strong
enough to to to express the properties
that everyone's capturing and it affects
dsl
the problem actually is in type
inference um there are
there are a whole bunch of type type
annotations here
which are needed um because the the the
compilation
simply isn't able to work them out from
its for for for itself
and uh unfortunately i think my my gut
feeling is although although this is
this is pretty cool i don't i don't
think it is
actually practical uh in use except
maybe in some very very specialized
circumstances because
because the the burden of the type
annotations is too heavy so okay so just
just
showing but i'm not showing you any of
the implementation here this is this is
this is what a user would get to write
so people uh okay so this is obviously
i'm sure i can see chris chris chris
nutty come sitting in in in
in in the audience he will he will write
he will write io
uh uh he will write code code in this
kind of monadic style sort of quite
quite comfortably but maybe maybe
that's not for everyone um but this is
this is essentially essentially the kind
of stuff that
that edwin showed you um this is a much
simpler well this is a this is an
example of just simply
um composing two two independent state
monads together what it's doing is it's
traversing a tree
it's counting the number of leaf nodes
and labeling each node as it goes
um it works i don't think i need to
actually run it to
to persuade you that it does so the the
crucial things that we've got here
are that you can see that whereas in if
you were just saying using the scala
said
um uh sorry scala z i pick your pardon
seeing us we're here um uh state manager
you
you would uh you would you would you
would you would basically pack all the
elements of your state into a single
statement
rather than trying to run two separate
statements independently or you would
use some other mechanism to
disambiguate um here we're able to um
to to compose a state so we can see our
state a little bit further up
uh is oh yes it's here so this is this
is roughly speaking corresponding to two
edwin states we have here a composition
of two
uh two integer states uh and they're
distinguished by
um by a couple of a couple of a couple
of labels effectively which which allow
us to
to pick them apart so there you can see
that the um
uh in the case of a leaf where we're
updating the uh
uh the the uh the count of the total
number of nodes
sorry the the we're updating the the
label um is that right
no we're updating the count that's right
and and the leaves don't get labeled
and in the case of the um
uh the the the uh the the non-leaf nodes
where we we are both
um recursively uh labeling the left and
right
uh labeling and counting the left and
right and we're also uh are updating the
labels and updating the accounts as well
um so the interesting thing here is that
is that you you can do things like sort
of arbitrarily swap the ordering of of
the of the uses of the
uh the uses of the different statements
which is which is which is you know you
you
would end up refactoring mono
transformer stacks if you're doing this
in another kind of mechanism so i think
edwin's effects dsl is
is is definitely a very interesting
interesting uh construct
now the real problem here and the reason
why i think this is a failure is that
you see that in
every step i actually have to mention
the
type of the hot the entire row of
resources being managed by the effects
uh dsl and i i i personally think that i
mean i've kind of hidden it away a
little bit by sticking a type alias on
it but ultimately i think
i think i think this means uh
edwin wins this particular contest
okay so i think we're about to get you
know dragged off with a hook or
something so i'm going to put the final
slide up and then
and then leave the final word to miles
this was meant to be on all on one
machine by the way if you're wondering
what
so we're actually going to leave the
the result of this to you you know who
who wins this battle we we like to think
that uh dependent types are the winner
because i say we're british and we don't
like to win
um so um so if you want to play with
idris you can
find a web page command install or to
work if you want to play the shapeless
it's all available on github
and um do we have anything more to say
well i
i i was very very impressed with
um so i i spent i spent a week and a
half uh i guess
uh working with um uh translating uh
attempting to translate edwin's effects
dsl from idris to scala
i was very very impressed with idris i
thought idris was a really very
interesting language i really enjoyed
the way that
um it managed to combine really very
significant
increment of expressiveness uh with
with really being you know kind of a
programming language you you would
actually
want to write programs in the post
[Laughter]
um so i i think my my takeaway is i
believe i believe the dependent types of
the future i think
i think that at least in the the part of
the
fork of forking the road that we're
going down between the the the
dynamically typed and the statically
typed people
i i think that our our future on the the
statically typed
uh fork in the road is inevitably going
to be dependently typed
i think idris is um is a very
interesting pointer to
where we're going to be ending up and i
think scala is interesting because
it provides us with a platform that we
can actually start playing around with
some of this stuff
we can do it now it does actually do
useful things there's a whole bunch of
the
um the techniques that that have been in
play
in uh in me attempting to translate
edwin's idris dsl
at in use in my in my
scholar generic programming library
shapeless um
and i i i i'm somewhat surprised and
and and flattered to know that there are
there are quite a few people out there
who seem to think shapeless
uh does uh useful and interesting things
for them so dependent types are already
in use in scala people are doing things
with them
i mean aside from the fact that it's
intrinsically dependently typed in in
its own way but there are things that we
can actually do
with this that are interesting and
important and useful and i i encourage
everybody to
to think dependent types okay thank you
for your attention
[Applause]